we are still less than a week into the
new mass mandate and some businesses say
they are feeling the impact
as some customers refuse to come back
until all restrictions are lifted
victoria saha tells us how folks are
keeping up with the never ending changes
at beach cafe in the southwest valley
your mask needs to stay on until you get
your order owner robin bradley says most
of her customers have been okay with
this
and some are not they're like well i'm
just walking to the counter and i said
well i realize that but
the rule is that you have to have one
when you walk in the restaurant until
you sit down
and he's like then then i'm leaving
bradley says all of her employees are
vaccinated and keeping the safety of her
customers is a top priority
which is why she won't hesitate to
enforce the rules
when that copy is over and we don't have
to do this anymore you welcome back
with new york city's approach to handle
the virus by requiring proof of vaccine
to enter indoor businesses
bradley says she won't want to do it
until she's forced to
but some of her customers say they
wouldn't mind showing their vaccine card
before taking a seat i have triple
vaccine i wouldn't
wouldn't bother me at all but someone
asked for it others say it's taking it
too far
a vaccination just enjoy a slice of
pizza my god asking for a vaccine to
enter a business
or to do any type of business is way
beyond
expectations for anybody i think over at
dimas pizza owner lujan dima says he
prefers the masks on
if there are a crowd of people in his
pizzeria if no one's here
i don't mind it you know people could
forget if they want
he also says his customers understand
the changing times and have been
following the rules
victoria saha 8 news now
now although the mandate that's going on
in new york city is not happening here
private businesses still have the right
to ask you for your proof of vaccination